thanks for coming here what's cool Josh
you pressured a student to reveal an
intimate moment in front of an entire
classroom you really want me to say yes
we're writers embarrass yourselves we're
gonna need you to take some time off you
look so much better hot moms cleaning
out her apartment it's very confusing
I'm gonna get rid of it grandma's still
alive
I don't want to live anymore I need my
grandma you're like my best friend I
want to be in heaven
all right give me the doll wait you're
gonna be with Grandpa very soon nothing
just fluffing the pillows I'm talking
about your gorgeous immigrant well I
just wonder if we could be a little bit
more intimate if there's a way to
incorporate just a little section okay
well we're basically on the same page
[Music]
hello hey anything okay there's not much
time who's on the phone
whose voice is it it's mine I hey
everything's a joke to you isn't it it's
no wonder you're trouble with your
school think for a second Josh they
wanted us to talk about making this a
safe space could you stop recording me
my I'd like to make this best have a
dialogue much better yeah oh great
I thought dad was your son
these kids at the jackpot one day
Caillou was a grandma
there are many people who love you back
your back
[Music]
you